hallo mein name ist luca und ich mache
youtube videos allerdings bin ich auf
dieser plattform ist der einzige der das
tut sondern millionen von anderen
menschen laden hier auch werke hoch
jedoch haben nicht alle videos aufrufen
sondern es gibt auch sehr viele videos
auf dieser plattform youtube die einfach
null aufrufe haben wie beispielsweise
dieses juwel zero zero nein dieses video
hier ist eines von vielen videos auf
youtube die null aufrufe haben und heute
schauen wir uns verschiedene videos an
die tatsächlich einfach keine aufrufe
haben
so geht das ganze video hier los es
läuft schon und es ist glaube ich bayern
münchen gegen lyon eine zusammenfassung
wir sehen hier ein angriff und der geht
direkt rein von franck ribéry keine
ahnung was sie sprechen und das ist auch
schon easy 34 jahre her wir können jetzt
allerdings einfach mal die ganze seite
aktualisieren und dann sehen wir schon
dass wir jetzt ja ein neues video
bekommen
das einfache nicht verfügbar ist das
nächste video hier ist final fantasy und
zwar ein lied
[Musik]
das nächste video
da würde ich mich auch nicht fragen
warum das keine aufrufe hat hier haben
wir irgendwas russisches glaube ich
irgendwie geht hier nichts los aber dir
das ist eine grafik okay kommt ohne korb
dann wird da was gesagt oder auch nicht
da wird jetzt habt ihr jetzt kann ich
russisch wir haben wir nun einen gips
kopien also ihr wird der tagewerk
genommen
sie läuft dem hinterher jetzt hat sie
eine idee und nimmt jaxx denn das verein
anscheinend wasser gas energie und feuer
wir aktualisieren die seite allerdings
mal wieder und findet als nächstes video
einige chinesisches oder es geht hier
nur um notepad + + oder irgendein html
krams glaube ich auf jeden fall wie man
kunden lernt das nächste video hier
zeigt uns bart de alexis also ein indoor
soccer hallen spiel und zwar dort einen
club 7 uhr gesehen dass einzelne hammer
geil ich glaube das ist aber nur dass 70
was hier gezeigt wird weil das video
geht ja gar nicht mehr so lange hier
stellen sie sich dann wieder auf und das
war's das war auch mein lieblingsverein
wir haben wir einen fußball video mal
wieder arsenal summer classic heißt das
ganze also wir sehen hier einen spieler
der dort lang läuft der alle austrickst
er läuft weiter vor erträgt sie noch aus
wir schauen aber das alleine macht nen
er steckt den ball durch und mein gott
kommt er an
und hier haben wir wieder ein video
erstellt den ball durch er läuft aufs
tor zu und schießt der ball ging nicht
rein das heißt wir haben jetzt eine
irgendwie sind dort nur fußball videos
hier aktualisieren das ganze mal wieder
für uns hängen doch morgen morgen ja
nicht so lange kürzel ja ja ja ja so
drei stunden war dann darin nächstes
video
[Musik]
ich meine ihr müsst euch mal überlegen
da haben irgendwelche lehrer so was
gemacht damit die schüler oder so dass
dadurch lernen und das ganze video müsst
ihr euch auch überlegen hat null aufrufe
das heißt keiner der das irgendwie
lernen wollte wollte das wirklich lernen
das nächste video er times böse ist
wieder nicht verfügbar
dann gehen wir mal aufs nächste video da
haben wir hier kommt man john ist auch
nicht mehr verfügbar
das nächste video hier ist wooga ist
auch nicht mehr verfügbar aktualisieren
wir mal da haben wir fans die fox place
fcb
was baut er da gerade überhaupt also da
hatten wir jetzt gerade noch den typen
der minecraft spielt das nächste video
hier aaron hsb irgendwie was
zu diesem grund ist leider kein
bildmaterial vorhanden
das sind videos wo ich mir wirklich
überhaupt nicht erklären kann warum die
gehen nicht mehr als 0 aufrufe haben
das ist allerdings auch vom video hier
meine damen und herren wenn es euch
gefallen hat das gerne mal ein like da
solche eventuell demnächst nochmal auf
videos reagieren die null aufrufe haben
schreibt sie gerne in die kommentare und
jetzt muss ich wussten das was jetzt
hier das war's jetzt hier vom video hier
können jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken ihr findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnenten
seid könnt ihr auch die glocken klickten
dann willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]